c'est un contest ne peuvent pas rester
impuni c'est pourquoi les anonymous mais
monde entier vont vous traquez oui
voulait bien mines qui tuent les pauvres
innocents
le groupe armé état islamique se fait
traquer en ligne par les pirates
d'anonymous qui menace directement les
terroristes de représailles
une position qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
d'ailleurs parmi la communauté des
pirates discute avec l'animateur de la
sphère voix soit mathieu céline alors
justement anonymus effet chrétiens oui
par un groupe de ce qu'on appelle les
bons pirates
donc les mauvais et les bons pirate est
donc un groupe de bons pirates legault
security group qui sont épris anonymous
en fait ce sont des dissidents
d'anonymous qui se spécialise dans la
traque aux islamistes et lui dise la
stratégie des revenus de l'année museler
pas bonne stratégie qui consiste à faire
fermer des comptes ou des sites liés aux
groupes islamistes et 8/10 et beaucoup
plus payant à les infiltrer ces groupes
est ensuite filer cette information la
force de l'homme est d'ailleurs ce matin
on apprenait qu'à des comptes
qu'anonymous appelait à faire fermer
parmi celles là ont trouvé le compte par
exemple de barack obama ou celui de la
bbc sont pas nécessairement déjà liés
qu'on puisse dire et à l'animus c'est
pas très organisée là comme entité c'est
vraiment un groupe extrêmement
décentralisée donc imaginer groupe qui
est menée avec les réseaux les réseaux
sociaux et environs dizaine d'années une
et bulleuse de cyber activistes liés par
exemple aux questions de lentilles
autoritarisme l'antifascisme la liberté
d'expression très proche de wikileaks
d'ailleurs fondé par julian assange ils
ont été fondés à peu près en même temps
et donc ils ont des canaux officiels
comme des groupes des comptes facebook
des comptes twitter mais ils sont
extrêmement décentralisée bon là ils
s'en prennent à l'état islamique où ils
sont ici sont assez actifs
oui les mailles font toutes sortes de
choses bessone de leurs débuts ils s'en
sont pris par exemple à l'église de
scientologie l'église de scientologie en
2008 ils ont été proches par exemple des
mouvements occupant le printemps arabe
également et donc une de leurs actions
préférées ce sont les fameuses attaques
par déni de service dont les attaques
ddos une attaque qui consiste à inonder
des sites de demandes de connexion pour
les rendre inopérants et d'ailleurs ils
ont été ils ont raillé dans le monde des
pirates parce que c'est une attaque qui
très très facile
à réaliser mais une chose est sûre cette
actuellement on se retrouve par exemple
du côté de groupe est armé islamique
avec des organisations extrêmement
décentralisé mais la réponse
actuellement les tons des suisses très
décentralisée avec anonymous go sécurité
groupe et les services de l'ordre qui
mènent des attaques chacun de leur côté
pour contrer bref on est dans une guerre
extrêmement asymétrique est extrêmement
décentralisée en tout cas sur le web ça
c'est sûr vraiment intéressant merci
mathieu au plaisir céline